what jobs have you had that like you
kind of can't believe that you're doing
it oh
well I got to be on the show called
disjointed with um Kathy Bates and it's
a crazy cool cast like unbelievably
radcast and that was awesome yeah it was
some of the most fun I've ever had on
working and it was also like the first
time I had a job for like
seven months you know because it was
like a big order they ordered 20
episodes right and I had never had
anything like that and I was just like I
can't believe I get to do this dude it
was awesome and then um there's one I
got to do
this movie called Hubie Halloween which
is the Adam Sandler movie and my scene
was with Adam Sandler and Shaq oh my
gosh and it blew my mind yeah yeah it
was like so like for a day I got to hang
out with Adam Sandler and [ __ ] wow and
that was a big like
all of my like fourth grade
fantasies are happening right yeah I get
a laugh with them and they're both
really nice people so nice unbelievably
nice
like chat both Shaq and Adam Sandler are
way nicer than they would need to be yes
like it's like Shaq don't you know your
Shack you don't have to be this nice you
know so funny and likes having fun and
it's just living life to the fullest
like at one point he was just like on
the stage just like on one of those tiny
Razor scooters just blasting around
laughing so hard I was like this is so
cool man like just having so much fun
that was a big dream yeah never in my
wildest dreams did they stink that's the
whole I mean I I just think about it
more and more as I get older it's just
like having fun yes that's like yeah
it's yes money's nice and everything but
like those days that you can have fun
yeah that's like
you know the Conan show could be
complicated at times like any like
anything like any in a relationship
multi-million dollar in your business
you know basically it's like yeah this
is a big business
um but I and I I mean I kind of
the thing and and I've talked to other
people that worked on the show the thing
that I just missed so much it's just all
the Laughing yeah so much laughing that
you get to do with these people every
day and everyone wants to be like hey
I'd like you know it's good to be around
funny people and then you're like around
funny people like not just funny people
world class yes like if there was some
sort of census they'd be like in the top
one percent and you get to [ __ ] hang
out with them every day I feel that way
all the time because it's like I live
with one of my best friends who's just
one of the funniest people and I hang
out with all of my friends are like
world class yeah comedian yeah and it
feels crazy it's like like you're
cheating or something something you know
that's what a lot of life my life has
been feeling like it's like is this okay
like I'm having a ball yeah yeah this
rules
yeah yeah yeah I feel kind of weird
saying it yeah but no it's okay
yeah it's good to be great we're having
fun yeah and the people that are
miserable listening to this I mean I
don't know listen to a self-help podcast
what do you listen to this for yeah you
think you're gonna learn something from
us no way no way we don't know any facts
whatsoever